I
there's a page to stare
singer and songwriter patrick james
began his musical career busking in his
home town of Port Macquarie in New South
Wales Australia fast forward six years
and he's releasing a single and album
spread it the change from just being a
busker to a live performer happen fairly
fairly sort of steadily I guess it took
me a couple years of busking maybe maybe
one or two to sort of get my chops up to
make me feel good enough to play a lot
of performance and then I was lucky me
luckily enough I moved to Sydney and I
met the right people who could kind of
steer me in the right direction and play
the right kind of shows his new song
bugs shows off his own brand of indie
folk which he says is reflected in his
album which will be out later this year
I guess the album for me is kind of
divided into two this there's a lot of
really kind of heavier band kind of
sounding tracks with a lot of harmonies
and instruments going on sort of the
rakia side of my music I guess and then
there's the classic kind of
singer-songwriter stripped-back piano
ballads and acoustic ballads as well to
the way I said it's sort of like it goes
in in two different waves and I sort of
wanted to make an album that had both
those things so i was a bit diverse he
was first noticed back in 2012 when
matchbox twenty's Rob Thomas saw him
busking and tweeted his praise to half a
million followers sweet from Rob Thomas
was one of those kind of crazy things
that happened that you don't have a
think will happen it's sort of a pretty
kind of cliche story in a way that it
actually did happen to me Rob Thomas
actually came up and bought a couple of
my CDs he'd been watching me for about
an hour and a half which made me of
course would notice
love to spread it and he's already
toured with big name artists like boy
and bear emma louise and pete murray
bugs is out now worldwide tina campbell
Sky News together now swain more is not
crawling on Martha